et avec nous pour parler de la situation
sur le terrain notre journaliste john
hutton watch bonjour johnattan bonjour
sun alors vous allez passer deux
semaines à kiev et dans sa périphérie où
vous avez tourné de nombreux reportages
avec james andré david gormezano vous
avez notamment été frappé par la
détermination des civils a résisté dans
la capitale oui c'est clairement l'inde
est l'un des points qui nous a le plus
marqué durant notre notre séjour de deux
semaines à kiev les exemples et ai été
vraiment nombreux et la détermination
comme vous l'avez dit c'est civile au
sein de la résistance ukrainienne était
vraiment très impressionnante je pense
par exemple à dmitro ce chef
d'entreprise qui vendait de la peinture
industrielle avant la version russe qui
aujourd'hui s'est lancé dans la
fabrication de gilets pare-balles
artisanaux qui fournit des médicaments
aux
combattants sur le sur la ligne de front
je pense aussi à ses directrices de
supermarché qui a décidé de rester
ouvertes coûte que coûte pour nourrir
pour ravitailler la population
et puis il ya aussi des femmes certaines
femmes qui nous ont beaucoup touchés
dans un dans un centre qui accueille les
déplacés qui ont fui les zones les zones
prises par les prises par les russes en
périphérie de kiev je pense à deux
femmes en particulier je vous propose de
regarder un extrait de d'un des
reportages que nous avons tourné et on
en reparle juste après
nous allons dans un endroit géré par une
menace
et une école mais c'est devenu un centre
d'accueil pour les déplacés
anna est l'une des volontaires qui
travaillent ici son mari soldats et
combat au front presque toute son unité
a été tué par les russes la veille
il m'a appelé l'année dernière
et m'a dit qu'ils étaient seulement 4
avoir sur
je ne veux plus entendre ces sirènes je
veux que les enfants retournent à
l'école
je veux que tout ça s'arrête stop ou
telle chose
la plupart des déplacés qui se réfugient
ici viennent dire pin et butch à deux
villes dévastées par la guerre au nord
ouest de kiev
valentina prépare à manger pour les
nouveaux déplacés qui arrive ce soir son
fils handicapé était costaud mais
lorsque les russes ont pris la ville et
son aéroport près de kiev elle ne sait
pas s'il est encore vivant
quelqu'un m'a dit que sa voiture était
toujours là bas je m'en remets à dieu je
suis sans nouvelles de lui depuis le 4
mars
la solidarité et l entraide sont devenus
la norme dans la capitale assiégée
avec la guerre à leur porte les
habitants n'ont plus d'autre choix pour
survivre
voilà une illustration assez édifiante
avec avec ses deux femmes de la manière
dont dans la population s'implique
s'investit pour aider les combattants
pour aider la population civile dont
canaille valentina ces deux femmes que
nous avons rencontrées à kiev un art il
ya la résistance civile mais aussi la
résistance armée vous avez pu jauger
cette résistance en vous rendant sur
plusieurs lignes de front en périphérie
de kiev oui nous nous sommes notamment
rendu sur deux verrous sur deux verrous
stratégiques alors d'abord au sud de la
capitale havas il kiffe 50 km au sud de
kiev à peu près et puis à brovary là
c'est au nord-est de la capitale et à
brovary nous avons pu parcourir des
kilomètres des kilomètres de lignes de
défense de tranchées de bunkers et voir
à quel point la résistance en l'espace
de quelques semaines s'étaient organisés
face à la poussée russes notamment face
à la poussée des blindés russes et nous
avons d'ailleurs pu vous de nos propres
yeux ces fameux missiles anti char dont
on parle beaucoup depuis depuis le début
de la guerre en ukraine nous sommes
notamment rentré dans un bunker où il y
avait de nombreux jaffelin ces missiles
anti char américain qui était qui
étaient entassées là et on voyait il
était encore dans leurs oeufs dans leur
conditionnement d'origine avec marc
caillaud et say you say donc c'était
c'était assez clair et donc ses troupes
un an seulement résisté à la poussée des
chars mais elles les ont même souvent
repoussées parfois ils ont gagné du
terrain on a pu le voir encore une fois
dans cette zone de brovary où parfois
les troupes ukrainienne parvenait à
repousser d'un kilomètre ou de 2 km les
forces russes et puis un dernier mot sur
sur cette résistance armée il faut aussi
il faut aussi souligner la présence très
forte de volontaires ces volontaires de
la défense territoriale qui font partie
aujourd'hui officiellement des forces
armées ukrainiennes et qui sont très
nombreux sur ses lignes de front
également notamment là où nous nous
sommes rendus près de brovary vous avez
aussi accompagner une unité de
volontaires encadrés par un mouvement
ultra-nationaliste ces groupes sont ils
très présent dans cette guerre alors
c'est un sujet à amagne est à manier
avec avec précaution ce sujet des
groupes des groupes nationalistes alors
oui ils combattent où ils sont présents
on les voit notamment à marioupol avec
le régiment azoff on voit même souvent
leurs images qui sont publiées sur
internet presque presque quotidiennement
le régiment azoff qui dit avoir
plusieurs milliers d'hommes dans ses
rangs même si c'est un petit peu
compliqué de vérifier ces informations
de manière très très précises en tout
cas ils sont là et ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut expliquer aussi c'est que ces
groupes alors ils sont ils sont très
présents même depuis 2014 dans le don de
basse il avait pris beaucoup de beaucoup
beaucoup de puissance et beaucoup de
visibilité avec la révolution de maiden
en 2014 et ce sont ces groupes ultra
nationalistes dont vladimir poutine se
sert pour qualifier l'ukraine tout
entière d'un de ramassis de nazis
quasiment alors là encore une fois oui
parmi ces groupes au sein de ces groupes
il y a des éléments extrémistes certains
flirtent effectivement avec avec des
thèses néo fasciste néo nazis mais à la
fois par rapport à ce que nous nous
avons vu et par rapport à d'autres
enquêtes qui ont été menées là-dessus
ils sont une minorité et c'était assez
frappant nous les avons accompagnés
pendant une journée entière dans un
centre d'entraînement puis sur une ligne
de front à l'est de kiev est clairement
nous avons vu rencontré beaucoup de
jeunes d'abord et puis de manière
générale des gens qui cherchaient
surtout un endroit où s'engager un
endroit où se battre sur sur ce front
est ce sont souvent des gens qui
viennent de la région de cette
périphérie est où nous étions est qui
qui trouvent là un moyen de combattre au
sein de la défense territoriale et qui
voilà qui ne sont pas forcément très
regardant sur sur l'endroit où ils
s'engagent et puis nous avons évidemment
posé la question aux responsables de
l'unité que nous avons accompagné nous
lui avons même soumis soumis des
accusations de vladimir poutine et il a
répondu très clairement où il a répondu
très clairement que oui ces éléments
extrémistes existé mais kick encore une
fois ils sont une minorité je vous
propose là encore de regarder un extrait
de reportage sur ce sujet danser lors de
cette journée où nous avons accompagné
ces volontaires
parmi ces nouvelles recrues beaucoup
tiennent un fusil d'assaut pour la
première fois
vous recommande ce jour-là un ancien
sous-officier de l'armée régulière
comme tous les cadres de cette unité il
est membre de l'organisation des
nationalistes ukrainiens
en zone est une force créée par nos
ancêtres pour défendre l'ukraine
c'est un symbole de la lutte pour la
liberté de notre pays et pour la
sauvegarde tout ce que les russes
tentent de détruire depuis 400 ans
l'organisation existe depuis près d'un
siècle et continue à séduire malgré son
passé sulfureux elle a activement
collaboré avec les nazis avant et
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale au
nom de la lutte commune contre les
soviétiques
une régiment azoff travis hector ces
mouvements ultra nationalistes sont au
coeur de la propagande russe qui clame
que l'ukraine est aux mains des nazis
oleg lui affirme que les positions
extrémistes sont minoritaires dans leurs
rangs
[Musique]
certains membres vont trop loin
mais ils ne sont pas représentatifs de
ces organisations
poutine nous traite de nazis
moi je leur réponds que ce n'est pas
nous qui tuons des civils
nous aimons notre pays est ce que ça
fait de nous des nazis je ne crois pas
merci johnattan welsh pour cet éclairage